let's do a problem on exponential growth
and if you think about it what we're
going to do here with bacteria it's no
different than what we did with compound
interest when we when we learned about
uh well you know interest and and and
the number e um because if you think
about well i'll i'll draw the analogy as
we do this problem but anyway this is a
compound growth problem or an
exponential growth problem and it says a
bacteria culture initially contains 100
cells and grows at a rate proportional
to its size
after an hour the population has
increased to 420
so this first says you know find the
expression for the number of bacteria
after t hours so in general anything
that when you're dealing with
exponential growth or exponential decay
or continuously compounding growth or
continuously compounding decay although
you'll you'll very seldom hear that term
you're the the the amount of whatever
you have as a function of time will be
in this type of equation i'll say
bacteria as a function of time so i'll
say b of t and i'll do it here
so b of well let me a let me do it here
b
of t bacteria as a function of time is
going to be equal to
the initial bacteria or the initial of
whatever we have if we're doing compound
interest it's the amount we start with
e
to the k
t
where k is kind of our compounding rate
and so in general if you have this i not
your initial
the initial amount you have and that
makes sense right because if t equals 0
this whole expression is 1. so
b of 0 should just be i not so if you
know what you start with and then you
have another point you can solve for k
and then you have an expression you have
what the first thing they want find an
expression for the number of bacteria
after t hours so my question to you is
first of all what is
i sub zero what is you what is your
initial number of bacterial cells well
they tell us they tell us right here the
bacteria culture initially contains 100
cells
100 cells
so we know that b
of 0 right when time equals 0 or 0 hours
that is equal to 100 where the unit is
cells
right and so if we look if we substitute
here t equals zero this is one so we
know that i naught is equal to a hundred
let me let me do that actually so b
of 0 is also equal if we look at there i
not
times e to the what k times 0 times e to
the 0 is equal to i knot so this tells
us that the bacteria at time 0 is 100
and then when we substitute here it says
the bacteria times zero is equal to i
naught so i naught must be equal a
hundred
okay so we're making some progress so we
know that
the bacteria
as a function of time
is equal to i knot
times
e to the kt
now if we just uk
then we would have done this part a find
an expression for the number of bacteria
after t hours well how can we figure out
k
well they give us another data point
after an hour the population has
increased to 420.
so that tells us so let me
oh my phone is ringing who is it
oh it's free satellite long distance i
don't i don't want to let me oh boy that
phone is so far away let me turn it off
let me oh so annoying
at least it's not dish networks anyway
so what was i doing oh so this tells us
after an
hour after an hour the population has
increased to 420 so that tells us that
b
of one right after one hour the
population is increased to 420 so b of 1
is equal to 420
which is also equal to
what if we put 1 here that is equal to
e to the k
t well what's t at b of one
t is one so e to the k right so 420 is
equal to 100 e to the k
and now we can solve for k and let's see
what we get so we divide both sides by
you get
4.2
4 point let me put e to the k on this
side
e to the k
is equal to 4.2
or
to solve for k we take the lateral log
of both sides and we get k
is equal to the natural log of 4.2 which
is going to be some bizarre number
and we can
we'll figure that out later with a
calculator so there we figured out using
the initial condition here we figured
out i naught and then using this extra
data point we solved for k and we got k
is equal to the ln of the natural log of
4.2
so what is that what does that leave us
so now we we we know the equation we
know k we know i not so we know that the
equation is so part a
part a
the equation is
b of t
bacteria as a function of time is equal
to the initial number of bacteria
100 cells
e to the kt and
k is
ln
of
4.2
that says 4.2
and all of that times t
so that's our function i know you can't
read that but we'll use it again so it
should make a little sense so then they
say find this is part
part b
find the number of bacteria after three
hours
so that that's pretty straightforward we
have our function now that at any time t
we can tell you how many bacteria there
are so let's figure out
the number of bacteria after 3 hours
so b
of 3
is equal to 100
times e to the
ln
of 4.2
times 3
and that number we could calculate if
you have a calculator e to the ln of uh
well let's see that's essentially what's
this going to be this is the same thing
we could actually figure this out
analytically that equals
e to the natural log of 4.2
if you if you have two things in an
exponent
multiply that's the same thing as taking
that and then raising it to the third
power right if we were simplifying we'd
say oh that's the same thing as just
multiplying that times this what's e to
the ln of 4.2 what's 4.2
right because natural log says well what
what exponent do i have to raise e to to
get 4.2 so if i
raise e to that exponent i get 4.2 so
that equals i didn't even have to use a
calculator look at that
4.2
to the third power
and i don't know what that is that's
going to be probably 70 something and so
we'll we'll do that later but that's
part b that's just that's just plugging
into your calculator that's part b
now what are they asking
find the rate of growth
after three hours
the rate of growth after three hours let
me do that in a special color
so what are they asking us for
well they're essentially asking us what
is the slope of this function after
three hours of this function after three
hours
or another way you could view it is what
is the derivative at time is equal to
three
let's do that let me
erase all this other stuff i have
i think we can erase all of this because
we've written down our equation here
you can erase that actually we could
even erase all of this because we've
just answered that that's just plugging
into a calculator at this point
i just want to keep our equation our
original equation so let's do part c
part c find the rate of growth after 3
hours so we just have to take the
derivative of
the bacteria function with respect to
time so let's do that
so b
prime
of t
it equals what
so what's the derivative of let's just
do the chain rule what's the derivative
of well so we can just have 100 constant
out there
times the derivative of this inside
function well that's just a constant
times t so it's just the constant so
times
ln of 4.2
times the derivative of e to the whole
thing well the derivative of e to the x
is e to the x so just the chain rule
tells us it's just the derivative of
this whole expression
so times
e
to the
ln
4.2
t
so that's the derivative at any time t
and then they want to know what the rate
of growth is after 3 hours
so b prime
of 3
is equal to
ln
4.2
all of that
times
well e to the
as we just did this in the in part in
part b
e to the ln 4.2
times 3 that's the same thing as because
this expression right here is just 4.2
this is times 4.2
to the third that's just a little bit of
logarithm math we did here and it's the
same exact logic and you know you all i
did is i substituted 3 here and
simplified
hopefully that makes sense to you if it
doesn't you might want to use your
calculator but
this all it's actually a pretty
important thing to know that
e to the ln
of x is just equal to
x
right because ln of x is essentially
saying what exponent do i have to raise
e to to get x so if i raise e to that
exponent i get x
so that's all i'm saying here that this
this right here is this is the same
thing as
e to the ln
4.2
to the t right because if you were to
simplify you just take this exponent and
multiply this and you get this
and so this is just
4.2
to the t
right actually that's i should have
written our original equation as that i
could rewrite our original bacterial
function equation as
times
using that same thing
4.2 to the t power actually that is a
simpler uh bacterial equation than this
one and so that would be even a better
answer for part a
and that makes part b even easier to
solve
and then part c well part c is actually
it was easier to keep it in this form
because taking a derivative of uh of e
is easier than taking a derivative of
another base and actually this is we
would probably want to convert backwards
so it's good we left it in that form
because it made the derivative all that
easier
but we could rewrite the derivative as
well we could rewrite this
as
b prime of t is equal to
ln
4.2
all of that times
4.2 to the t right i just took
i just took this
sorry now i took this
and i replaced it with this
anyway i got a little bit messier than i
wanted to but then their final question
is when will the population reach 10 000
so let me erase what we did with part
c
when will the population reach ten
thousand
so let me write what we've already done
a little bit neater
we know we knew that part a b of t is
equal to 100
e
to the
natural log of 4.2
t and i said well you know that's the
same thing
as 100
times
4.2 to the t power
and they say when will the population
reach 10 000. so they're essentially
saying when is at what time t is b of t
equal to 10 000. so we could just say
is equal to this
and actually i'm going to use this one
because i'm going to take the natural
log of both sides it just makes things
simpler
e
to the
ln
l
n 4.2
t
so you could divide both sides by 100
and you get
is equal to
e
to the
ln
4.2
t
and now we can take the natural logs of
both sides of this equation
right and so that we get what
we get let me draw a divi well i'll do a
different color
we get taking the natural log of both
sides of this the natural log
of 100
is equal to well if you take the natural
log of e to something
you're just left with the something
and you might want to review all the
logarithms if if you found that a little
confusing but that if you take the
natural log of this side you're just
left with the exponent
so that equals
ln of 4.2
t
and if you want to solve for t you just
divide both sides by ln to 4.2 and you
get t
is equal to ln of 100
divided by the natural log of 4.2 and
that will be an hour so how many hours
does it take you just plug this in your
calculator and you will get a number for
the number of hours
hopefully you didn't find that too
confusing and actually since
just to hit another point home we could
have used this equation i mean it's the
same thing right and what we would have
had we would have had
times 4.2 to the t power is equal to 10
divide both sides by 100 and you get
4.2
to the t is equal to 100
and so to solve this so you're
essentially saying log base you would
essentially want to take log base 4.2 of
both sides of this so you would say t
is equal to
log
base 4.2
of a hundred
and i went over this in the exponent
prop in the logarithm properties video
but it's it's a pretty useful thing to
know in general how do you figure out
you know your calculator has two bases
it has log base 10 and it has log base e
which is a natural log how do you figure
out log base of another number of 100
well the simple answer is you could take
natural log of this
and divide it by the natural log of this
you could also take log base 10 of this
and divide it by log 10 base of this log
base 10 of this
anyway hopefully i didn't further
confuse you and i will do this was
actually exponential growth
and you could replace these words you
could say you know instead of bacteria
culture you could say a bank account
initially contains a hundred dollars and
grows at a rate proportional to its size
which would mean compound interest and
then you could say after an hour the
population has increased to whatever
four dollars and 20 cents
and then find the expression for the
number of so essentially you'd be trying
to figure out the compound interest rate
and all of that but this is the exact
same phenomenon that the larger you grow
you're going to grow by an absolute
value more than that
anyway i'll do more of these problems
because they can be a little confusing
and i'll do one on on exponential decay
as well
see you soon